now we come to afrofuturism 2.0
and this is another wave the rise of
astro blackness
and the black's bucket of arts movement
we're actually in april futurism 2.0
right now afrofutures and blossoms into
all these different types of genres and
there's even new ones emerging like
african futurism
and black quantum futurism too there's a
great
quote from and term from the reverend
andrew rollins
that talks about the rise of astro
blackness
it's about a person's black state of
consciousness
released from a confining
and crippling colonial enslaved
mentality
who becomes aware of the multitudes and
varied possibilities and probabilities
within the universe
so astro blackness shifts us from this
modern era
of blackness to a planetary perspective
in response to the challenges facing
black life
in the early 21st century now
i call 2018 the year of the panther when
the black panther film came out
and you know it's was wondering like how
did futurism 2.0 end up on
local abc news as i did i was able to
articulate
what the black panther meant to me the
smash
box office hit and i can tell you when i
was at the community screening
at the grand theater in oakland i was
thrilled
first of all to see oakland on the
screen being portrayed
and then next flying into this beautiful
etch city of wakanda it's the whole
community in the theater we're just like
yes you know it's just one of those
moments
you see there was this exhibition going
on in
the schoenberg center for the study of
black studies
it was called the alchemy of the black
imagination and you had this wonderful
exhibition of
fantastic artwork that imagined black
people
on different planets in the galaxy
on earth with new types of technologies
it extends what afrofuturism 2.0
does is it extends the edges of radical
black art
it's transnational it's trans contextual
it's diasporic it's a cultural worldview
for interrogating eurocentric motifs
the linear constructions of past
present and future so it goes further it
extends afrofuturism 1.0
even more you know tiffany barber
and ronaldo anderson have this wonderful
quote where they say the black angel
of history has traveled across beyond
space and time
to prepare us for a future african zion
beyond this place
of wrath and tears see it carries and
extends
where we've been before
so 2.0 the version of afrofuturism
extends the reach of
radical black visual art literature
theater social and applied sciences
and critical theory in the us and so the
alchemy of the black imagination
ushered in this wonderful movement
called the black speculative arts
movement
that was co-founded by ronaldo anderson
and john jennings and others
you see the one thing i want to make
clear here too is i'm one head talking
but with me and alongside me are
thousands
hundreds millions of people that are
part of this wave of afrofuturism
some people are into african futurism
black quantum futurism and the black
speculative arts movement
it's a wave that we're experiencing and
we're just riding that wave right now
you see it's all about tracing the black
fantastic
less than two percent of card-carrying
professional futurists
identify as black but that doesn't mean
there aren't plenty of black futurists
and foresight strategists and futures
visionaries abundant in the streets the
arts
at the protests in tech labs
so tracing the black fantastic refers to
what richard eitan
talks about the minor key sensibilities
generated from the experiences of the
underground
you see we can see it around us right
now and the protests going on
across the nation those minor keys are
being
played tested experimented extended
so tracing the black fantastic means to
recover
past progressive liberating alternative
futures and sprouting them into the
present
we also have these fantastic science
fiction authors women authors
who are breaking barriers like nk
jemisin with this season
and binti by nedi okorafor winning
hugo and nebula science fiction awards
we have graphic novels coming out like
the black panther party an infant item
by tim fielder that really talk
and meet the past with the president you
see the black panther party
began in the 60s and when i looked at
their 10-point program
i agreed with every point they made they
were talking about reparations
free access to quality healthcare and
education
where we realized that in the film of
the black panther
and are still struggling with that right
now in 2020 unbelievable but we are
and we have this wave and renaissance of
movies like
sorry to bother you and the black
klansmen
and these wonderful murals that were up
on 9th street in oakland by tariqa lewis
that proclaimed wakanda and oconda here
are ready to
interrogating you know this lineage of
black history in oakland there's erica
huggins too
a former leader of the black panther
party who envisions
how to speak about white privilege and
so it's we have these leaders these
these elders like tarika lewis
and erica huggins and angela davis
who are our sages who are these black
visionary thinkers that are still alive
we are learning so much from them
so tracing the black fantastic as our
cultural vibranium
it's about reading their radically
hopeful possibilities into a future
augmented with progressive values and
fused with more black
soul you know clr james really has this
great quote he talks about that the
fundamental task
is to recognize the democratic socialist
afflow queer utopia society and record
the facts of his existence
so that we can see these scenes and
moments are read as outposts of a new
society
and walking around oakland especially
right now
in san francisco and oakland you see
these wonderful art pieces
done by black artists and some white
artists too
talking about their inspirations about
the future where black lives matter